good afternoon good morning my name is
John Quackenbush and welcome to the
genetics and genomics conference live
today I'm going to be telling you a
little bit about the work that I and my
colleagues have been doing really
looking at Big Data and healthcare and
biomedical research ok so what I'll try
to do is talk for about point 9 50
minutes and then questions so it's a
pleasure to be here with you and I look
forward to spending the next hour with
you so see so again so first background
in some disclosures I'm a professor of
biostatistics and computational biology
at the dana-farber cancer institute I
also a professor of computational
biology and bioinformatics at the
Harvard Chan school of public health
like a lot of you I have many other
academic titles so I still people as an
academic rather than paying or they give
me more titles make me sit on more
committees in addition I'm on a number
of advisory boards none of which are
relevant to anything we're going to
present here today I also co-founded
Geno space a precision medicine company
the work we do at Gina's base really is
built around developing software and
tools to support precision medicine and
I may briefly mention one example of
some of the work we've done but again
none of that is really relevant to the
vast bulk of what I'm going to present
here and if I do mention it I'll clearly
call it out so you know I'm a data
scientist at heart and what really
excites me is having access to data and
the reason for that is the data really
drives revolutions in science so I went
to look for a quote that describe them
describe the importance of data in
driving innovation and I found this
quote every revolution in science from
the Copernican heliocentric model to the
rise of statistical and quantum
mechanics from Darwin's theory of
evolution in that
selection to the theory of the gene has
been driven by one and only one thing
access to data and if you think about
that that's absolutely true every single
model you consider in science if we have
that model what we try to do is to use
new sources of data so we can take that
model and make predictions the data then
either allows us to verify the model or
if we falsify the model if the model
doesn't match the data and the
predictions from that model don't match
the data and we're able to collect then
we have the opportunity to go back and
build a new model and to take that model
and then further test it so it's really
data that drives our ability to better
understand the universe and to build
models that better described the
properties of elements meant universe so
I mentioned I look for a quote and try
to find when the truth is I couldn't
actually find one so they went in the
wrong direction I went the wrong
direction again but this is actually a
quote from me so if you share with your
friends there will be a famous quote one
day in fact I know is too long and a lot
of you are probably on Twitter now so
this is the Twitter version with 115
characters including spaces but the
reason I like this quote is that it's
absolutely true that data drives
innovation and that's a big part of the
reason why it's so exciting to be
working today at this frontier of data
and health and biomedical research so
what are the driving friends what's
really making it possible for us to
begin to look at this data in a
large-scale way and begin to link it to
biological information and I think one
of the things that's really driven this
discussion and remove the field Ford is
the cloud the cloud is really a buzz
word and that sort of reflecting the way
people present it you can show rooms
full computers you can show really
space-age looking assemblages of
computer systems you can draw little
cartoons but really what the cloud means
in a practical sense is it today we have
access to very large scale
mobile computing infrastructure and we
can call it up on demand that rather
than building a large-scale data center
we can bring to bear large-scale
computational infrastructure with a
credit card and an internet link so we
can build large-scale data computing
resources on demand and we can scale
them and relatively low cost and we can
keep them up to date as systems
modernized without making a big capital
investment so that access to large scale
powerful computing and reasonable cost
is really driven a lot of our ability to
think about dealing with massive
quantities of data and what are the
challenges in work in this area is
actually people's concern about moving
health care data into the cloud but the
truth is that the data security breaches
that we most often see are not people
hacking into cloud-based systems rather
the people losing unencrypted flash
drives or laptops on the bus or in an
airplane or leaving something behind in
a cab or even in a hospital setting
somebody walking up to an unsecured
terminal it's not somebody physically
challenging the infrastructure the
large-scale data storage and computing
resources and very rarely someone asking
it so there been a number of papers
published about this some white papers
really trying to debunk some of the
myths about data security in the cloud
and the truth is that most cloud-based
systems if you have the right software
encryption and data protections in place
are no less secure whether it's in the
amazon cloud or the IBM cloud or your
own private data center so dealing with
data security large field data is a
solvable technical problem one of the
other really interesting elements that's
influenced our thinking about Big Data
quite a bit is the iphone and you might
think well that's because you can use it
as a data capture device and that's
absolutely true but in fact when I think
about the iphone and one of the defining
moments for me and thinking about access
to big data and use of
data was really thinking about why the
iPhone became so popular well it's
gotten to be a better phone the
initialized phone actually wasn't a
great phone but if you think about that
song what made it so popular so widely
adopted aside from the style factor was
the fact that that phone could be
infinitely adapted to each individual's
unique needs and preferences and as we
start to think about access to large
scale data one of the principles in big
data analysis is we've been bringing the
computing to the data rather than moving
the data around but if you have the data
in one place you mean computing to it
what you realize very quickly is that
they're different constituencies that
one different types of access to the
same underlying data so if we have
combined clinical and genomic data in a
precision medicine setting the questions
the clinician wants to ask at the point
of care what do I do for my individual
patients are very different than the
questions a researcher once asked if I
take this group of patients and compare
it to that group of patients what are
the differences between them so as we
start to think about building
infrastructure for big data and health
and biomedical research one of the
things we have to think very carefully
about is how we take the resources we
have and actually adapt them to provide
interfaces and tools that meet the
unique needs of the different user
communities the great thing about this
is we actually have access to many
different sources of large-scale data so
a lot of the work I've done over the
course of the last few years has really
been built around the idea that we can
take genomic data whatever type it is
and Link it to clinical data with the
goal of relating the different genetic
and genomic features that we see to
meaningful clinical endpoints so can we
find transcription patterns and gene
regulatory patterns that we can link to
different outcomes and disease or to
identify different sometimes can we
identify mutations that we can use to
predict which patients will it won't
respond to therapy can we look at
integral
different data types to better
understand the function that causes
cells or functional alterations that
cause cells to move from a normal state
to its at eastbay but in fact it's only
a small slice of the growing universe of
data that we have access to so we can
start to think about a drawing
information from a variety of different
sources for example we run clinical
assays we have lots of tests that we run
on patients and editions of genomic data
on Steve alerts a colleague of mine is
really a pioneer in a new field called
green elements will be an imaging data
and extracting quantitative features
from imaging from the imaging modalities
that we can now collect so we can take a
CT scan we can identify a tumor and Hugo
can pull out features from that tumor
what you go and I started working on
some time ago with the idea that we
could use those features as biomarkers
but more importantly we have imaging
data and mutational data on the same
patients we started out the pushin could
use an imaging data and the features
that hugel is extracting to predict the
mutational status of tumors and the
truth is we now have a number of
different tumors weiland imaging
features are very predictive of certain
mutations of the tumors which makes
perfect sense the imaging data really
represents phenotype and if we believe
genetics that genetic alterations should
be time to phenotypic alterations but
you can go beyond that you can start to
think about drawing information from
drug research and animal models and
integrating that you can start thinking
about drawing information from claims
and looking at reimbursement and
treatment and healthcare systems you can
start to monitor patients at home and
collect real-time data you can start to
look at the measured man using iPhones
and fitbit's and other devices to
collect information to begin to think
about whether changes in patterns of
activity are correlated with disease and
you can even look at things like social
media data to try to predict outbreaks
or understanding these transmission
networks and really a lot of the methods
that we use to look at cellular networks
gene expression networks social networks
or
all very similar what they really rely
on is having accurate curated sources
robust large scale integrated data so
it's very exciting as you starting thing
about pulling this data together there's
actually a graphic I really liked it
comes from the net at netapp corporation
they build large-scale disk arrays you
can download this from the web it's the
body of the source of big data and if
you look at this there's a fist in here
I really like one of them i like to call
out is the estimate that by this year
the average hospital in the US will
generate about six hundred and sixty
five terabytes of data working at
dana-farber in this part of the heart
medical system i can tell you that none
of the hospitals here are average are
all possible to generate far more data
this may be a community hospital but
what it really speaks to is the fact
that we're generating in the hospital
where we were terabytes is not petabytes
of data annually and that presents us
with real opportunities but there are
also challenges things like medical
imaging archives now represent between
fourteen twenty and forty percent of the
data and the hospital systems and in
fact a lot of the data in hospital
systems they even give it a push for
electronic medical records is
unstructured data what that means is
that extracting meaningful information
is often a challenge and in fact if we
think about electronic medical records
they weren't really designed to support
the scientific enterprise what they were
designed to do is to support
reimbursement and the management of the
hospital system so the information is
often there that's often coded in ways
that make it difficult to extract it
simply and easily so we have to invest
in doing that but if we do we have a
tremendous source of information that we
can use the start to really plays all
the other data we collect into the
context of human disease so has have we
seen a transformation of medicine well I
think we look at Big Data a big data is
really having a transformative effect
because we've seen increases in the 3
v's the volume velocity
idea of big data and so we have access
to unprecedented quantities of data the
volume is really refers to the vast
quantities of data we can now mass and
we're soon going to be generating as
much data in one minute as we did
between the beginning of time at about
2008 I this is a tremendous quantity of
information velocity is the speed in
which we generate data and from almost
any measure you can think of our ability
to rapidly collect data whether its
genome sequencing or monitor activity
using a Fitbit has really accelerated
over the last few years we can get data
and a tremendous rate and nearly every
medical instrument you can think of has
a network interface and the ability to
output data in real time the variety
refers the complex multifactorial data
that we can collect and in fact we think
about human genomic data from small
samples in using new sequencing
technologies we can compute or we can
collect mutational profiles we can
collect transcriptional profiles we can
start to collect epigenomic profiles and
so we have these very interesting
integrated data sets that we can tie to
lots of other data to really start to
build predictive models some people add
two additional ease the value and
veracity of data I'm not going to talk
about those but you can think about what
they mean and you really think about how
we use the data to add value to what we
do and how we really assure the
truthfulness the veracity of the day we
can collect but if you think about
transformation of medicine these new
technologies that provide all this data
are really changing the way we think
about must biomedical research well we
used to always think of it as purely a
laboratory science or really a
laboratory plasma clinical science maybe
with some statistics to run large trials
in fact what we're seeing increasingly
the biomedical research is transforming
itself from a laboratory of clinical
science into and Information science the
challenge of courses we look at this
information age is to bring together all
this information
a way to better address fundamental
problems in health and biomedical
research but also to have practical
applications so that in patient care
what we'd like to be able to do is the
increase efficiency improve outcomes and
decrease costs and so that lends point
is actually important while doing basic
research we often don't think about
using this information at the point of
care since often we're drawing on the
same data and information we have to
think about this in context and a very
good justification for building the
infrastructure for precision medicine
research is precision medicine
applications where we can use the data
we collect to actually have an impact on
healthcare and healthcare outcomes so do
we need to do that why is this important
well there's really a need for data
driven precision medicine and i'm going
to show you two slides that I think
really underscored this the estimate is
that this decade in the u.s. we're going
to see a thirty-three percent increase
about a thirty three percent increase in
the prevalence of cancer so cancer is on
the rise it probably reflects aging
populations as much as anything else
however that increase of about one third
is actually reflected in a two-thirds
increase in the cost of treating
patients so the cost is rising faster
than the incidents here in the US in
this decade and so what we really have
to think about doing we've heard this
debate time in the end is coming up with
better ways to manage costs now if we
think about managing costs a big part of
what we think about is giving patients
the right therapy at the right time to
be most efficacious and that's what we
call or refer to as precision medicine
and there's a lot of excitement about
precision medicine in a large part
because we've developed as a community a
number of therapies that actually target
particular mutations or particular
variants that we can measure using
genomic technologies so we can think
about a number of these that occur
across the spectrum of cancer or they're
probably more than any other disease
indication but in fact cancer is not
alone that a number of different disease
states we have now targeted therapy
that are directed towards particular
genomic alterations or particular
mutations and so in precision medicine
what we'd like to be able to do is to
use that genomic data with other
information to arrive at the best
therapeutic protocol to produce a
positive response from each patient then
the thought is that if we do that we
manage to do that that what we can do is
even if we're using expensive drugs to
reduce costs and improve outcome by
making patients healthier sooner and
more effectively so that's the promise
how well is it played out well this is
actually a slide from data adapted from
the odds that some information at the
FDA and what's interesting is if we look
at targeted therapies and oncology's if
you look in the upper left you look at
therapy like gleevec where the those
drugs are highly specific and highly
effective in patients who carry the
mutation that would indicate that those
patients in fact you between the treated
with the drug but many of the other
drugs and the response rate of the
response fraction is shown in black many
of these other drugs if you look at them
even if we target the therapies to the
patients who should be receiving
therapies only a small fraction of the
therapies are effective only a small
fraction of the patients respond so what
that suggests is that we need even in
those targeted therapies to continue to
look for better biomarkers and continue
to look for better sources of evidence
and information better sources of data
to inform the evidence and information
to make the appropriate decisions for
our patients so if you look at the
importance of this there's actually
really nice so an interview present in
the cancer letter with the cliff food is
the president of ASCO and what he said
was that even within the NCCN the
national cooperative cancer center
network which is the group here in the
US that really sets guidelines for the
standard of care and treating cancer
patients even within the NCCN certainly
the majority of precision
that are enshrined in the NCCN
guidelines are not supported by a high
level of evidence right how we're
treating patients even in evidence-based
medicine is still largely anecdotal and
what that suggests to me is there's a
real opportunity we can collect the
right data put in the right form and use
it effectively then we can have a big
impact on how we treat patients and
manage disease so the solution to this
problem obviously has to be driven by
data and access to data and we need to
think about that volume velocity and
variety of data and how we use that
effectively to really develop better
ways of treating the patients we manage
so when I think about this problem I
actually look at this as an opportunity
to take the genomic data we can generate
and look at the spectrum of health and
biomedical research and look at using we
relive the spectrum of disease and these
response so there's some things we have
no influence over like lifestyle and the
environment there's some things which we
can't control like chance but if we look
at the genomic data that we have
available what we can begin to think
about doing is looking at that life
cycle disease can we do a better job of
predicting genetic risk as we have maps
more evidence surely we can can we do a
better job of early detection of disease
with new technologies we're now at a
point where we can start to think about
looking for things like circulating
tumor cells or doing non-invasive
prenatal testing to look for the
presence of fetal DNA in the mothers
bloodstream and to identify anomalies
that might for example predict trisomy
21 Down syndrome or trisomy 13 or
trisomy 18 or other particular defects
that might be important to try to manage
in some way prenatals but once we start
to Detective these what we really like
to do and this is where the rubber meets
the road precision medicine is the
stratified patient stage them
appropriately based on the molecular
features and then direct them to
therapies that are most likely
to produce a positive response and give
those patients good quality of life so a
lot of the work I and my colleagues have
done and it really this whole community
is done over the last few years it's
been driven by access to data from
technologies like DNA arrays which have
really laid the groundwork for a lot of
what we want to do but in fact today we
have much more exciting opportunities to
use sequencing-based technologies to
collect integrated complex multi only
data on the same patients and to begin
to think about how we really is those
more effectively to look at this entire
lifecycle disease so what's really
driven this has been the cost of
sequencing and as that cost of
sequencing is fallen we've seen a real
explosion in a number of methods and the
number of methods to begin to take that
data into interesting things what I look
at this actually I could put this graph
which is adapted from data at the
National Human Genome Research Institute
into some context the first human genome
was sequence in the year 2000 at that
time the cost of the genome project was
billions of dollars but the estimate was
the start of new genome in 2000-2001
would cost a few hundred million dollars
the time that it would take is actually
once it would be done by people working
in sequencing factories around the world
collecting and massive data it was a
very very difficult challenge but
shortly after the sequencing of the
genome the cost started falling and
actually fell it a pretty appreciable
rate so if you look at the top part of
this curve what you see in fact is a
time in which the cost of sequencing was
dropping by a factor of two every 15 16
17 months so people often compare this
initial drop to moore's law the law in
computer science the empirical
observation that the cost of processing
drops by a factor of 2 every 18 months
or the number of transistors on a chip
doubles every 18 months or processing
not speeds increased by a factor of 2
every 18 and so people compare that to
moore's law and in fact you can make an
argument some of that drop really wasn't
and computing technology but in 2007 new
sequencing technologies were introduced
the alumina genome analyzer the applied
biosystems solid even the 454 sequencing
instrument really started to change the
way we think about generating data and
in fact that resulted in a precipitous
drop in sequencing costs we're from 2007
on the cost of sequencing was dropping
by about thirty three percent per
quarter okay so every three months the
cause was dropping by a third it almost
made more sense to wait if you had a
large study to generate data rather than
to jump in because three months later
you can sequence a third more samples so
if we look at this time it was really
interesting sort of conceptually to
think about what this meant then the
really turning point for me was in 2009
where the cost of sequencing crossed
$100,000 because when I look at that I
would actually say honestly that if my
wife or son had a rare tumor in 2009 I
wouldn't mortgage our house and sequence
their genomes to try to better
understand how we might treat that tumor
today the cost is about a thousand
dollars which means you can pay for it
with a credit card it's less than the
cost of buying a high-end television and
the cost of sequencing is no longer a
barrier to generating data and if the
cost remains low and continues to fall
what that really suggests we should
think about is not the barriers to
sequencing for the barriers to using
sequence data when it's available to
address a whole host of questions so
what are those bearable people sometimes
raise the specter of cost and this is
actually a very influential paper that
was published by Elaine Mardis in 2010
where she speculated on what would
happen is the cost of sequencing dropped
to a thousand dollars if the cost of
doing analysis remained high and people
still today when I talked about this
opportunity that presents itself with
genomic data and health and biomedical
research about what the real cost of
analysis
now how people come back if they lost a
hundred thousand dollars then the fact
is the cost of analysis depends on what
you want to do with it and in 2010 the
state-of-the-art analysis was really a
very hand crafted analysis if we didn't
have something obvious that fell out of
it so the way I tend to think about this
is as an economic universe build around
the cost of doing genetic data analysis
so the kind of work Elaine Mardis was
talking about then the graphics aren't
working out very well here sold see what
happens as we move forward but the
research applications should have been
up in a little circle in the upper
left-hand corner or up like this when
you'll need this Dipper right hand
corner the upper right hand corner of
the graph so there is a place in the
upper right hand corner we're looking at
almost the entire genome we're looking
at that data in a very careful way in a
research application we're digging in
we're trying to find the root cause of
mutation then we can link in some kind
of meaningful way to the phenotypes we
observe and while that's an interesting
problem and it's a research problem in
fact is not the kind of analysis that we
could even begin to expect we have a
major impact on health care if we sort
of think about other applications though
there are opportunities for example in
clinical trials to look at a smaller
number of candidate biomarkers and
analyze those and in fact as we look at
a relatively fixed portion of the genome
and we're asking very specific questions
like are these biomarkers predictive or
not predictable response the cost is
much less because we don't require a
room full of highly qualified
bioinformatics analysts biostatisticians
and clinicians and send together and try
to tease out what's happening we just
look at the data and ask very simple
questions as we transition this to
looking at clinical applications and I
apologize this graphic to turn out
either but what it should really
represent a sort of a continuum of
applications for less than a thousand
dollars then look at between some small
number of genes and most of the entire
genome and while we can still think
about those clinical applications
in the upper right-hand corner like the
diagnostic Odyssey some poor child that
has a rare genetic disorder we don't
know the cause we sequence that child we
sequence and siblings we sequence
parents and other relatives and then we
get together and try to tease out what's
happening or we can think about those
applications those applications in fact
tend to be the exception not the rule
but really what we have to start
thinking about is the cost of analysis
being less than the cost of data
generation and that's where precision
medicine is actually going to have its
major impact in the clinic but if we
really think about this in clinical
medicine today in any disease the number
of approved and actionable variants is
small typically far less than ten it in
that instance the cost of analysis isn't
even a thousand dollars it's far far
less because what we're doing is we're
looking for the presence or absence of
specific genetic bearing that we can
link in an approved includes a
conclusive way to a particular
therapeutic intervention and so in that
domain there's really an interesting
opportunity to try to take data and
information that we use and linked to
something which is going to have an
impact on treating patients and an
impact on outcome so the major cause
there is building the systems to provide
those links and maintaining them and
then building maintaining the databases
and knowledge bases that feed those
decisions so is it a
hundred-thousand-dollar analysis it
depends on what you want to do with the
data but if we're going to have an
impact in precision medicine it simply
can't be it's got to be a small fraction
of what it actually costs and generate
the data so what we need to do is
develop tools and the knowledge base to
link genetic variants to improve
standard of care therapies to really
drive precision medicine forward but to
do all of this and to make sure we have
that knowledge base to make sure we
continue to grow or understanding we
need to make an investment
big data research so there was actually
a really wonderful report published by
the National Research Council in 2013 it
was called frontiers of massive data
analysis and what they did in this
committee was they looked at how to take
data on this large scale to wrestle with
the volume velocity and variety of the
data we can now collect and to really
think about putting it into a biomedical
context to drive forward health and
biomedical research and what they
pointed out in this report was that the
challenges associated with massive data
go far beyond the technical aspects of
simply storing that data and they don't
underplay the importance of storing data
and managing it but those are
technologies that exist today and can be
adapted from other domains google book
ebay they all wrestle with much larger
quantities of data that we never think
about dealing with they collected it a
far greater rate than we have to worry
about technologies exist for managing
those data we have the thing about data
security and data access protocol we
have to think about a whole host of
questions that are very important but
there are technical solutions for those
as well what this report goes on those
days are the key element meaning big
data challenges is the development of
rigorous quantitative and statistical
methods we need better ways of analyzing
the data we collect because without
those it's quite possible just turn data
into something resembling knowledge what
it actually is not and it's overlooking
this foundational aspect of big data
analysis may yield results that are at
best not useful and at worst harmful
right we need to think carefully about
how we analyze the data we can collect
and we need to develop new methods that
are going to enable that so about a year
and a half ago from colleagues and I sat
down together as part of really thinking
about some of the new challenges and new
opportunities through presenting
themselves in this big data universe and
we asked ourselves what are the key
challenges we actually got 17 faculty
members together from the Harvard
chancel
calcium's dana-farber cancer institute
from MIT Lincoln labs and we sat down
and we describe the challenges and
opportunities in Big Data and if each
one of us presented our challenges
whether we were looking to environmental
health or genomic medicine whether in
genetics data or imaging data as we
started to present our challenges what
we discovered was that those challenges
fell into a relatively small number of
buckets and that those challenges are
things that we all face in one way or
another and looking at data so one of
those challenges is just the problem of
pre-processing and normalization can I
take data from two different instruments
whether it's a satellite and a
ground-based monitor for environmental
sensing or it's to MRI machines in the
same hospital across the hall from each
other can I put the same patient of MRI
machines and know in a quantitative way
those images are the same so we have to
be able to do that we have to scale
normalized preprocess data so this it's
useful we also want to identify hotspots
those elements that we actually want to
analyze later a second challenge that
was universal is the one of data
integration how do we take these diverse
data types and put them together in a
meaningful way a third challenge was
reproducible research how do we actually
use the data that we're collecting an
ongoing fashion as a way to continuously
validate the findings that we make on
earlier data sets to make those findings
in future findings more robust how do we
look beyond simple correlations that
start to put together networks something
I'm going to talk about later and then
how do we really assure data access in
utility in meaningful ways not only that
address the technical challenges but
then also addressed some of the data use
and data as access challenges so I'll
talk about each one of those very
briefly the first is the problem of
normalization and batch effects batch
effects have to be removed to have to be
normalized this is actually a paper that
was published a few years ago I think
2010 by some of the real thought leaders
in this field Rafael Irizarry Jeff week
number of others
in this paper that appeared in nature
what they did was they looked at genomic
data from a variety of different sources
in published studies and what they
shelled was that even in studies where
the data were normalized properly they
could find features they could find
elements that were not predictive of the
underlying biology but in fact were
predictive of where the data were
collected so these batch effects exist
and what they then went on to show is
that these batch effects in fact are
very common in many many published data
sets across domains and so this paper I
really think is a call to action to use
better methods for normalizing and
preprocessing data but also to make an
investment in developing methods the
second area I mentioned was the one of
integrative analysis this is really sort
of an ongoing challenge that we all face
doing given a variety of data we can
collect that data has really allowed us
through those technologies that produced
it it really allowed us to collect a
variety of different types of data and
the kind of work I do we think about
bringing the other multi-homing data in
meaningful ways but in order to make
sense of it what we need to do is to
link in clinical and phenotypic data we
have to look at systems like electronic
medical records which really weren't
designed to capture those but we have
the rest with the fact that in the data
we're looking at their multiple often
hidden dependencies that we'd like to be
able to find because sometimes those are
biologically meaningful but depending on
our application we also have the correct
for because we don't want to over fit
our model by making five measurements of
the same thing so we really have to
think carefully about how we build those
integrative models and again it's an
area where we need to make an investment
into future research I mentioned
reproducible research there are lots of
examples of this and I think what are
the great things about our community is
the fact that we tend to make data and
software available so we can look at
this overall problem this is actually a
problem I and some of my colleagues
published a few years ago
looking at two large pharmacogenomic
studies and the great thing about those
studies published simultaneously in
nature the cancer cell line encyclopedia
in the Cancer Genome Project was that
they made their data available what we
wanted to do is we wanted to build
predictors we wanted to look at this
pharmacogenomic data genomic profile and
response to drugs and we wanted to build
predictive models who would take those
genomic profile and allow us to predict
which cell lines would respond when we
did that when we actually compared
different that when we compared the two
different studies and try to build
models on one and predict on the other
what we found was that our predictions
failed horrible so we decided to go back
and look at the cell lines and drugs
that were in common out of the hundreds
of cell lines in each one of these
studies profile what we found with 471
cell lines that were in common we then
looked at the drugs and unfortunately we
were only able to match 15 drugs out of
the hundreds that were profile
nevertheless this gave us an opportunity
to ask where the problems were in this
underlying taught these underlying data
sets so the natural place that we
started was by looking at gene
expression data everyone over the years
has raised questions about the validity
and reproducibility of gene expression
data and the great thing is in this
study we found the gene expression data
were highly concordance between the
studies and I think that really reflects
the fact that ten years ago there are a
lot of papers published in which people
pointed out the inconsistencies in gene
expression data so that as a community
we got together we develop standardized
laboratory protocols and standardized
analytical methods so the two groups can
now produce very reproducible very
comparable data on the same elements
even though they're geographically and
temporarily separated on the other hand
wield is the correlation between the
phenotypes measured by drug response for
most of the 15 drugs there was very very
poor correlation in response so what
that suggests to me is what the
community needs to do is to go back and
standardize the reports are the reporter
assays that are used to measure
on standardized the protocols for
generating the data and standardized the
analytical approaches and if we can do
that these large-scale pharmacogenomic
studies will actually become far more
reproducible so this is just an example
but it points to the opportunities like
in gene expression where we've been
successful and the opportunities
pointing to the future we need to
continue to invest to develop methods
that allow us to do this kind of
reproducible research but again it was
the availability of that data in real
time from these groups that allowing us
to find the problem and suggest ways in
the future to continue improve them we
need to assure data access and utility
knows my last point this is actually an
example that i'll use that comes from
some work that my colleagues did it
Jeanne of space and this is really
centered around delivering reports to
physicians when the company started what
they wanted to do what we wanted to do
was really produce reports that we could
deliver dispositions using modern
technology looking at mutations in
cancer and when we started to talk to
the physicians what we thought they
would want I really slick web-enabled
tablet enabled reports but when we look
to the physicians not necessarily the
major academic medical centers but in
community practices what we found was
they didn't want web-enabled pool they
wanted simple PDFs that they could look
at in five or ten minutes between one
patient in the next to look at the
information to see it presented a
graphical way that would draw their eye
to the important key elements and they
could read and draw a conclusion very
quickly about how to best treat their
patients which is good but the thing
that really depressing I started hearing
the story was what they wanted was a one
or two page PDF and the reason they
wanted a PDF and again eighty-five
percent of cancer patients in the US are
treated in community practices these
practices many of them have electronic
medical record systems those that don't
have paper based systems but even those
of the EMRs one in PDFs so they can
print
and then manually scan them into the
Myanmar's the text had to be in a fun it
was actually readable after being faxed
multiple times and I think this point to
one of the great challenges in Grady
inequities and our health care system
the vast majority of patients are still
being treated in systems where
electronic management of information is
still primitive right the ELR that most
people are using most positions are
using we're designed to turn a room full
of files into a disc bulge apex so going
forward this is going to be ongoing
challenge the good thing is even those
physicians as they started to look the
report recognize that what they wanted
to do is dive into the underlying data
look at the underlying happens and so as
a company move forward what we started
doing is producing web-enabled kaolin
able reports tribute brasile use okay so
we have the thing about data we have the
thing about access we have to think
about how we make information usable to
different constituents as a form of use
but the thing I wanted to talk about
today is an application and that's
really a set of networked methods so
what it is do is describe one or two
then yet so I'm going to point you to
another talk later today that it takes
up i'm very interested but really all
this is built around the way we think
about biological networks and for me as
a research scientist this is one of the
areas i'm most excited about so what do
we learn from networks well a lot of my
thinking in this area has really been
driven by work that I've done in the
past and questions that I've gotten from
referees I think a lot of those
questions are foolish unless you're my
referees in which case those questions
were brilliant but a lot of the
questions I think missed the mark and
the questions that I find most difficult
to rationalize is the question about
many times and try to write about
networks very often referees will ask
how do you know that this is the right
Network and I think that's the wrong
question to ask when they're asking me
that question you really dig into it
what you start to recognize that they're
often asking you well why doesn't this
network look like a picture in a
textbook and as I think about it the
answer is it shouldn't look like
textbook if we think about that question
what we're really asking is if I can
make some representation of the network
doesn't look like the network that I
might expect to see in a normal tissue
but in fact if we think about disease
processes either through mutations or
miss expression elements within the cell
are going to change their potential
interaction partners by not being
expressed in the same time in the same
place in the cell or they're going to
change their ability to interact with
other elements by the introduction
mutations which may affect how
transcription factors can bind and
influence other teams downstream may
change how two proteins can interact
with each other so the topology of the
network is going to change and so if I
build a network for a disease state and
I want to compare to a normal network
it's obviously not going to be right in
the sense that I can draw it as a single
Network and know that all those
connections are there and in fact if I
look at different subtypes of disease
the topology of those networks are going
to be one would hope fundamentally
different they're different phenotypes
through different mechanisms driving it
the networks themselves should reflect
those different phenotypes and be
fundamentally so the real question then
shouldn't be in the network right but
can we choose out meaningful differences
between the networks that inform our
understanding of biology so I really
transitioned from this question of
asking is the network right to asking is
the network useful in informing my
understanding of the diseases of each
process so that's going to be a big part
of the thesis I'm going to present as I
move forward talking about networks I'm
actually going to talk about an
application modeling gene regulatory
networks and this is work that I did
largely with my colleague gtu and
tymberlee glass who was a postdoc
working with us she's now an assistant
professor at the Channing division of
network medicine and Harvard Medical
School on this message we published a
few years ago I is called panda Panda is
an acronym for something I never
remembered that has to do
passing messages but if you do
bioinformatics software development the
thing you should know is the most
important thing is having a to name for
your methods and nothing is cuter than a
panda so pen is a way of modeling
information flowing networks and we
really started by asking questions about
what are the few processes I really
believe I understand well and that's
transcriptional regulation so the output
from transcriptional regulation is in
RNA and we have opportunities to measure
our and age and seeking expression
arrays using RNA see so you measure the
output but we ask what drives the
expression that RNA was the assembly of
an RNA polymerase complex that's enabled
typically by the binding of specific
transcription factors within the region
of that gene so if we can centralize
this all you can think about is actually
a model in which the transcription
factor encoded by a different gene is
communicating with its downstream target
and so as GC and can be and I started
really thinking about this problem what
we recognized with input from Curtis on
our was that if we look at this problem
it was really a problem communication
any communications theory there's a body
of work centered around what's called
message passing or affinity propagation
the captures this information exchange
problem or that models is information
exchange problem in this model what we
have our transmitters and in our case
those transmitters of transcription
factors we also have receivers these are
their downstream targets and in this
process in message passing any
communications process in fact involved
two parties the transmitter and receiver
I'm telling you about this methyl you
are trying to learn about this method if
I were to give you a quiz at the end of
the presentation if you did perfectly
well get a hundred percent then no one
would argue that you did your job and
that I did my child but if I were to
give you a quiz and you were to do
poorly to be at thirty percent
if someone didn't hear this presentation
if someone didn't want you listening to
this presentation there'd be no way to
know whether it was because I did a poor
job of explaining this method or you
were distracted checking emails while I
was talking about message capacity so
without that external validation someone
simply looking your score we know
whether the failure and information
exchange was your fault or my fault now
what we can do is we can actually define
functions on the transmitter sides and
the receiver side that we call the
responsibility for the transmitter and
the availability for the receiver the
transmitter has to transmit that
information but if you're not there to
receive it no information for us if
you're sitting in front of your terminal
I'm not telling you about it no
information flows so we can actually
define mathematical functions based on
measurements we make but the bottom line
is with just two parties in this
discussion we have no idea of knowing
where the information flow breaks down
but if we have a much more complex
network what we can do is actually it
early estimate these functions on each
edge and then come up with a summary
score for each edge telling us whether
the information is flowed or hazards so
the way we approach this problem is to
start with a gases to the network
structure and that's based on using chip
data and transcription factor motif data
to postulate an initial network
structure then what we do is take other
sources of data and information
protein-protein interaction data gene
co-regulation data we calculate these
functions on each edge we update our
network model and then we iterate the
process and in fact we iterate the
process until it converges to a final
network model we have some degree of
confidence or we really come to realize
is that what this model does is it
optimizes information flow through the
network so we can start with a guess at
the network we can start with data and
then what we can do is build different
models for different phenotypes and go
back to that question I asked how have
the networks
change how do they differ so one of our
first applications was to look at two
different subtypes of ovarian cancer the
different based on their expression of
genes associated with Manta Genesis so
as a paper describing this
classification that appeared i think in
2009 then what we did is we took the
largest available data set the Cancer
Genome Atlas data set and ovarian cancer
we classified samples based on whether
they were angiogenic or non angiogenic
and then we calculated networks for
those two subtypes ultimately what we
did was compared those networks and we
look for differences and in fact this
analysis was really foundational in our
thinking about how we measure look at
networks because as we started to look
at these networks we realized that nodes
in the network's the genes that we
represented in our models were always
there what changed were the connections
the edges so the take-home message for
me from this analysis that has really
been important for us moving forward is
it be edges are the atoms in the network
there are the indivisible elements we
want to find so we built networks if you
build networks you have to make
representations like this so in rather
the angiogenic edges and the blue or the
non angiogenic edges if you compare
these what you see is there a difference
is the network topologies I'm taking the
quiz you'll have to name these later but
fundamentally their differences in the
network so we tried to look at these
diagraphs aren't very useful but kim p
actually came up with a very nice
representation and which we looked at
the transcription factors and look at
their targets and a paper describing
this analysis has just been accepted so
i'm not going to spend a lot of time
talking about the details but if you
start to look at this kind of spirograph
image of the transcription factors and
their targets around the outside what
you recognize is that some of the genes
seem to be controlled by a single
transcription factor but there are
complex patterns of regulation start to
emerge from this
and so what kitty did was she went back
and looked at those combinatorial
patterns of interaction and found that
many of them occurred far more often
than one might expect by chance so it's
simple hypothesis in comparing these
network models is that the differences
are really reflecting differences in the
regulatory processes that control the
genes that are being expressed and so we
started to look at these we came up with
hypotheses for the ways in which we
could look at what's known about
regulation in the process of
angiogenesis and what's reflected in the
data that are introduced me reflecting
the model that were able to build from
available data and actually hypothesize
interventions that could be used to
inhibit angiogenesis and in fact a
number of the interventions are known to
be effective in inhibiting action
Genesis so what the model presented us
by we need differences in the edges with
hypotheses about how to potentially
treat the seeds we've now applied panda
to a wide variety of different disease
states and in every single instance what
we've been able to do is to extract more
meaningful information to give us
insight about the underlying disease
processes so we're very excited about
the potential to do this but rather than
show you some of those examples I wanted
to talk about something else jetting is
part of an interesting conundrum and
thinking about networks and network
models and that's even embedded in what
I already told you but I said we
compared the angiogenic and non
angiogenic subtypes what I said is we
wanted to find none network for the
angiogenic subtype and done network for
the nine angiogenic subtypes and then
compare them but if we build two
networks for two different phenotypes or
even one network for a single single
phenotype what we recognize is that in
that phenotype there's a variety of
different manifestations of that
phenotype and every individual
manifestation is probably represented by
a slightly different network in the same
way if I look at a single piece of
tissue every cell is going to have its
own unique
network and so I say we build on
networks the angiogenic subtype or run
network from a non antigenic subtype I
actually lied to you drawn away a bunch
of information we set thresholds on the
interactions and above some threshold we
say there's an edge below the lower
threshold the edge is gone what about
the individual examples how do we
extract the networks for the individual
samples well this is the question we
wrestled with for a long time can we
take gene expression data and pull out
the network for a single individual
sample so this is actually a problem
that Kimberly glass Matthew Tong who is
a postback student and I along with the
number of other colleagues we're talking
about for quite some time and Matt had a
really simple idea that's based on a
very simple assumption what i can do is
i can take a collection of samples and i
can build an aggregate network for those
sample so the antigenic subtyping
ovarian cancer i can pull out an
aggregate network and i can look at that
network and represent it as an average
over all the samples but matt said well
what if we take that and pull out one
sample and we build a second aggregate
network is that aggregate network the
same and the answer is they differ
slightly those two networks have subtle
differences and so one simple way to
think about it is the difference between
those networks actually reflects the
fact that at one samples been pulled out
it reflects in some way the network of
that individual sample so if I take
these two networks and essentially do
linear algebra on them to subtract them
what I might be able to do is to pull
out the network for that individual
sample and so we developed a method we
have a paper now that we're about to
submit really Matt and Kim being and
then read Kuchar worked on this project
and the idea is really simple benin
lioness this method now with another
cute name what we can do is we can look
at different
networks compare them and from that
estimate the contribution to a single
sample so in practice what we do is take
a collection of sampled build an
aggregate Network pull out one put it
back in pull out the next one put it
back in plot the next one each time
estimating the network for those
individual samples so we did this we
needed to test that we have a few of
them one of the most interesting was the
first test we did using G cell cycle
data so this is actually a time-course
data says it comes from gene expression
arrays in a two color array we built
networks for each individual sample
what's shown here in color and on the
right hand side is the correlation in
gene expression measures between
replicates we have two replicas of this
time course the apparent aunty
correlation between replicates just
represents the fact that here these were
dive swap experiment so it looks like
his name's correlation was really a
correlation but the interesting thing
was we use panda to build our network
models and if we extracted individual
sample Network spices pull one out
process what we can do is look at the
edge weights and what was really
interesting was the edge which showed
good correlation both within and across
replicas and this is really exciting to
me because what this suggests is that
the edge waiting so we're calculating
across to replicate are capturing the
same features of the same network at
that individual time point so you can
look at the net what the edges that
actually change the most and this is the
figure that really excited me as we
started to pull this project together
well your should what you see here in
the heat map is not gene expression
levels but edge weights and these edge
weights if you look at them on
oscillating over time if you look at the
edges that are oscillating they actually
represent transcription factors that are
known to be involved in the cell cycle
so what we then did was we took those
transcription factors and their targets
and we plotted the oscillation in the
edge ways for the transcription factors
and in the gene expression
the targets and if you look at the right
hand side on your screen what you'll see
is the edge weights shown in black
awfully with twice the frequency at
which the gene expression level from
South fossil and we first saw that we
were puzzled but then we realized this
is exactly consistent with what we would
expect from the Panda mod what did
transcription factors are doing
essentially sending a message that said
turn on turn on turn on turn on a model
is capturing what you'd expect from the
underlying biology so for us this was
really exciting leaders what it pointed
to was a way in which we can extract
single sample information they captured
essential features of the underlying
biology are the network's read sample
right I don't know but they're very
useful in modeling what happens add the
yeast cell cycles and again we have a
number of other applications when we can
use the then that would mean a paper
that's being submitted this week that we
can use to really validate and justify
the use of this month so we're very
excited about it and what might provide
the last piece which I would love to
talk to is how we solve the G wasp
puzzle my understanding the COS puzzle
is very simple complex traits are
complex there's actually a consortium
called the giant consortium that's
trying to take all the gy studies they
can get their hands on and look at
common features common phenotypic
measures across those phenotypes and
across the studies they found a few of
the phenotypes they can look at things
like height or weight BMI I published a
number of papers over the last year or
so looking at large aggregate studies in
this cases the paper that appeared to
eat your genetics genetics looking at
the genetic variants of influence height
and they look at something like two
hundred and forty thousand individuals
and so by testing these and looking at
genome-wide Association studies they
were able to explain about twenty
percent of hype using almost seven
sniffs to get the twenty one percent
they needed to go to 2,000 to get the
twenty-nine percent they needed to go to
9,500 I complex traits really represent
a lot of snaps a lot of genetic variants
that interact together in a very weak
way to produce the phenotypes we observe
they're very few highly penetrant
Mendelian disorders we can find by doing
snips so how do we r ashwin is how do we
do with this in g us well a very
interesting approach is something that
John platic and I and the number of
others have been working on for some
time and John actually is going to
present what I think is a pretty
revolutionary approach to looking at
networks and network structures they can
teach us a lot on to inform our
understanding of complex traits so
that's going to happen later today John
deposed up with me but he's a really
bright guy so I urge you to tune in and
listen that topic that Hugh very excited
about what he presents so what do we
learn from all as well networks provide
unique insight into biological systems
but data is really what's going to drive
the rise of precision medicine we can't
build those networks without the
underlying data once we build those
network so the properties over those
networks give us an opportunity to
discover key factors that we can start
to associate with disease and there many
unexplored areas that are right for
investigation I just give you a small
snapshot but I and many of my colleagues
have been thinking about probable many
of you have been thinking about i just
want to say that this is a really
exciting time to be a data scientist the
challenge those we have to be careful
and this is a website i really love do a
google search for spurious correlation
what you'll find is this website did
tyler vegan who it turns out as a
student it was a student at LP still is
at Harvard Business School put together
Tyler actually got large publicly
available data set put them together in
a common format and then provided a
statistical inference tool looking
correlations in the data and so he calls
the spurious correlations
is one of my favorites is at the top of
the page it's the correlation between us
spending on space science and technology
and suicide by hanging strangulation and
suffocation and I just look at the time
to realize it's probably wrong because
when spending on science goes down I get
more depressed but you can find this
correlation of the data this is actually
another really good one it's the almost
perfect anti correlation between the
number of honeybee producing colonies in
the u.s. shown in blue and juvenile
arrests for marijuana possession
suggesting that if we legalize marijuana
or don't arrest kids the honeybees are
going to survive and then last but not
least during the winter this is my
favorite the number of people who died
by becoming tangled in their bed sheets
is correlated with total revenue
generated by skiing facilities in the
u.s. so if you go skiing don't sleep
under the covers sleep on top of your
pad right just because you find
correlations and data doesn't mean those
correlations on me so we need to make an
investment in new methods i started with
a coral close with to business or
william gibson the science fiction
author the future is here yet it's just
not widely distributed yet so i'm
showing you a little bit of where i
think the future is but my favorite
footage from enrico fermi i use this all
the time before I came here I was
confused about the subject after
listening to your lecture I am still
confused to the higher level so I
applause them they went a little bit
late but I want to thank you all for
your time for being here and then what
I'd love to do is spend some time
answering questions so we have a remote
moderator who's involved in running this
conference and he's put up pulled out
some questions I'm going to start to
step through those I'll read the
question to you and then give you answer
you want to jump off you stay on this
one I won't be offended I won't know
that I won't be offended but thank you
all very much i want to thank Don for
organizing meeting and I want to thank
you all for the opportunity to let me
share some my work and so the first
question and I apologize if I'm angling
but his name I'm very bad at reading
but the first question is from Tammy
Moorish from the University of Toledo so
what cameos was for the various
individuals who are nonresponders versus
responders it seems that the insight
from understanding the molecular target
of these various drugs would be critical
do you know what retrospective studies
are followed up in these situations
where the molecular target is now so
this actually the first I think that
graph I showed with data from the FDA
and the truth is most of these drugs are
simply given and the follow-up studies
aren't done and what that suggests is
that moving forward if we really move
into an environment where we have
precision medicine assay being done
regularly on patients that what we can
do is collect those data and use them
retrospectively to really try to
understand whether the particular
variants which are or are not predictive
most of the major academic medical
centers here in the US and then many
centers around the world our strategies
collect genomic profiling data on cancer
patients and so it really does provide
us with an opportunity to do new more
informative data-driven and
evidence-based things going forward but
that whole field is still in its infancy
so there's tremendous opportunity to do
what I think are very interesting things
second question from Melton jube that
the analytical edge laboratories what
are the chance of the patients suffering
today from diseases like lupus or
fibromyalgia would get actionable
information from actual information from
these kinds of genomic a phase and the
question that the answer is that in a
lot of diseases the kind of information
we have available today is still very
limited there are places like cancer we
have a large body of informative data
that are tied in some way to the
standard of care and so the earliest
incursions of precision medicine into
the practice of medicine i'm probably
going to be in oncology but beyond that
there are a lot of other applications in
your psyche
a cure disease and cardiovascular
disease their number of genetic variants
that are tied to pharmacogenomic
response that can be tested today and
will be regularly tested in the future
in neonatal screening every state in the
u.s. in most countries around the world
provides some kind of genetic testing on
to look for any errors of metabolism
that are tied to particular mutations
and so their opportunities there to do
testing today and to expand that testing
into the future for diseases like lupus
and other diseases our understanding is
still primitive but the way to advance
our understanding to find those actual
markers is to collect the data so the
more genomic data type in clinical data
we have the better our chances of
actually being able to find those
biomarkers I bail with you zippy from
thermo fisher scientific you raised a
number of excellent points for the badge
effect problem who is doing the best
working controlling for this our
sequencing vendors tackling this problem
with controls or is it still left to the
researcher generating the data I don't
know who's doing the best job I always
point to rock valley or as arya as being
one of the real pioneers raphael
developed RMA which was really one of
the first robust normalization tools of
course there's chain we with each if
evan johnson who developed methods for
doing batch control + batch effects like
combat Jeff league there's really a
community of people who come out of
biostatistics who they're working on
this problem for a long time in genomic
gas phase and if I had to point to the
leaders it would be almost any one of
the authors on that paper I refer you to
earlier in terms of the instrument
manufacturers I still think this is
something which is left to the people
generating the data but you're
absolutely right having better standards
and having opportunities to look at
those data across multiple different
institutions for standard samples is
going to give us better tools for
improving
compare things raphael ahren easy from
the AC from the AC Komachi of cancer
center I once heard that we are reaching
a point in science or it is less
expensive to repeat large-scale analyses
sequencing than buying computational
storage what's my opinion about that
storage is expensive how you store data
actually have to reflect part of a
larger discussion centered around how
you're going to use data in clinical
application it's actually mandated here
in the US the clinical data be stored
for a number of years before it can be
destroyed so we have to store the data
irrespective of what else we do with it
you can lose samples if the samples are
handled properly so there aren't always
situations where you can recapitulate or
we collect the data and the truth is the
cost of storage is falling so we have to
come up with good storage strategies I
think a lot of this really reflects the
problem that a lot of people have and
they try to maintain their own data
centers you rapidly run out of room for
storing the data so you have to do
something with it turning off disk
drives and putting them in clauses or
warehouses is an expensive proposition
even and of itself and so cloud-based
solutions in a lot of ways really
represent a good way around this problem
of trying to wrestle with storing to you
from Jamie Lee from the osu south
centers about the cost of genome
sequencing you said is the thousand
dollars now I'm wondering if the cost is
only for human genome Ricci Qin Singh or
for the de novo genome sequencing of any
organism the cost of genome sequencing
you know what the real cost is is
probably more than a thousand dollars to
Reese equant the human genome to
sequence a new mouse genome Ritchie no
that's argument sequence there's you
know cost comparable to humans but it's
on the order of a few thousand dollars
so is it exactly a thousand dollars
today no but it is low enough that it's
a barrier that it's not a barrier for
generation I think the answer that
question is yes the data generation is
largely become a commodity so the
tremendous opportunities for us to
generate massive quantities of data but
sequencing new organisms is still more
expensive and a lot of that really is
because we have to generate additional
sources of data to try to build
scaffolds and put genomes back together
I mentioned whole genome sequencing in
fact when we look at clinical
applications whole genome sequencing at
least in most areas there's still a long
way off from being clinically useful it
probably makes a lot more sense to
sequence exomes or sequence targeted
gene panels with where for the same cost
or less we can get much greater depth of
coverage you need coverage about things
that we can actually say something about
today ah Ozma xia from nust we still
lack such studies in developing
countries what do you think it has the
effect on interpretation of data from
complex of use so i think this question
is absolutely on the mark that when we
talk about looking at data for complex
phenotypes we really have to sample
complexity and diversity of both the
genotypes and phenotypes so well it's
difficult today i hope what we see is a
continued drop in the cost of generating
data because once that data is generated
our ability to analyze data is almost
without limit with matt to it national
borders i mean access the data analysis
technology is still a real bargain
almost wherever you are especially with
cloud-based resources so um I think this
question is absolutely right in sort of
calling in to light the fact that we do
have to do broad surveys the most
important challenge though today is to
do as broad a surveys from can with
sufficient quantities of clinical data
or phenotypic data that we can draw
meaningful conclusions kjs sir ken from
MIT
how precise does the data need to be to
get significant quarreling Tory results
and precision medicine can you work with
imperfect data sets its phenotypic data
and wearables are likely to produce
again I think this is a great question
any data is going to be in precise
that's simply truth about how data is
collected every data has error bars you
should have error bars every day to have
some challenges associated with it
self-reported clinical data from
patients in fact can be cleaner than EMR
extracted data where the EMR is not
really designed to collect that clinical
data so the data is going to be
imperfect and often in precision
medicine if you look at the scale of
data that we deal with with Google or
Amazon or other big data analysis
problems in biomedical research it's not
always the big data problem it's the
mapping data problem the way around that
messy Jaina problem is to collect large
quantities of data that's as accurate as
possible so you know this really examine
basic statistics if you make a lot of
measurements if the measurements are
reasonably accurate even though there's
noise in those measurements we're going
to move toward hopefully something that
represents underlying truth so it is a
challenge if we have really bad
phenotypes are not going to be able to
draw any conclusions but the better they
can be the better the results are going
to be from Laurier mendez rios at the
NIH NIAID wins which institutions are
effectively working and ethical issues
of big dating uses I think there are a
lot of different organizations that are
addressing trying to address this
problem I think one of the real
challenges is that fundamentally all of
the data we collect is identifiable that
if we think about genome sequencing data
your genome is uniquely yours we've been
a number of studies that have shown that
I can take your genome use public
records and link this in for me
in such a way that I can uniquely
identify individuals and so that's going
to be an ongoing challenge dealing with
health care and biomedical data is going
to be an ongoing challenge I think we
have to think about moving away from the
identification start thinking about
encryption and permission engorda use in
building tools to provide access the
data we need to think that in better
ways about informed consent and how we
involve individuals in the process but
you know what's really interesting too
is we do have these ethical issues is it
privacy is often a generational issue so
my nephew is in college his mother is
his facebook friend and he's sharing in
real time things he's doing today that I
wouldn't many years after college
probably admit to my mother that I did
when I was in college if I actually did
them so privacy is sort of a
generational thing and in fact we think
about the data we freely share often
that data is much more revealing about
us than some of our health and
biomedical data so I think there are a
lot of challenges here I think the NIH
should be applauded for funding research
into these ethical issues I think the
Wellcome Trust and other funding
organizations are wrestling with these
and grappling with them and providing
support for them so I think it's going
to be an ongoing challenge but I think
it's going to be one that we as a
community have to address on to be able
to work with the data going forward so a
couple more questions from I apologize
this is the name that may have trouble
with Samuel a Watsu egerman from
cranfield university thank you for the
presentation my question is the aging
population contributing significantly to
the increase of cancer incidents more so
than lifestyle or environmental factors
I think aging plays a role we know that
cancer is definitely a degree of a
disease that reflects on DNA damage that
accumulates over time but the
environment lifestyle play a role as
those genetics as does chance
and I group aging into environment
because aging reflection away the
environmental exposures that we've had
but you know if you think about this
problem i have a friend she's in her 40s
she was in her early 40s when she
developed spontaneous lung cancer she
never smoked a day in her life has no
obvious environmental exposures had no
family history of lung cancer so as we
think about her disease I mean clearly
seems to me that she drew a bad card
somewhere along the way and accumulated
mutation have led to the development for
TVs it was caught early surgery
cheerdance oh she's fine but we really
have to think about this the complex
problem with multiple types of data ah
pas de James from the cane and
ministries how do we connect patient
data to network forty to sixty percent
of us hospitals with independent small
groups of physicians question number one
in question number two some cancers
resolved from agribusiness fertilizer
chemicals and years and environmental
insults how to society individuals
manager so the data linking and data
connection problem I think is an ongoing
challenge as a country we've made a huge
investment here in the US to install
electronic medical records but those in
many instances are very primitive and
don't provide a simple way to link
patient data together I think we
actually really need to go back and the
sort of go to the questions about ethics
to really think about how we put
patients back in the center and involve
them in an ongoing way and the
consenting process and really make them
partners in research and that doing that
is probably the single biggest way we
can advance this field and get people
involved in a meaningful way there are a
lot of ethical social legal issues but I
think we all have a stake in the game to
see disease is cured and to see diseases
preventive you know the question about
fertilizers an environmental exposure I
think again the more data we have the
more evidence
we'll be able to collect to be able to
link information together in meaningful
ways to help us inform not only health
care decisions but also positive
decisions and then one final question
from kami Moorish again from University
of Toledo and looking at disease versus
non disease networks do you envision
that these networks could be used and
diagnosis at some point in time if so
are the limitations and barriers of
using disease versus nominees network to
diagnose disease and how does like the
phenotype compared to more traditional
definitions of in Antigua I think even
in cancer we're starting to recognize
that these clinical definitions often
don't tell us enough about the disease
in breast cancer we now recognize there
are multiple months of phenotypes and
those phenotypes are very informative
for treating patients the part of the
standard of care and they play a big
role in what we've seen is an
improvement in survival in those
patients so molecular phenotypes are
clearly important disease they help
define subtypes that we can't define
clinically phenotypically even using
histopathology and they provide chances
are the mechanisms that might be
important for developing therapeutics
and we start to think about networks and
individual sample our hope is those
networks to become diagnostic this
lioness method I presented this one way
to pull out the individual example
networks that were encouraged about but
whether or not we can actually use those
in a clinical diagnostic setting I think
it's still a long way off this isn't the
only method lots of people are working
this area and I'm giving you a snapshot
of what my research group is done but I
think one of the things that's been
great about working is not what
inference field is that like the
genomics field before there are a lot of
opportunities for people to get together
and to share data and it's a community
that shares data and shares methods and
I think doesn't recently effectively so
I've been talking for a long time on its
product for well I started a little bit
late but almost for an hour and a half I
know people at other things to do I have
some other things
today but I really want to thank people
for the interesting questions it's been
very rewarding knowing that at least
five or six people out there rather than
be talking alone one of the other
questions I got was what is its like
what is it like to present it an
interactive conference like this I think
there's some great things one of them is
that I was able to walk from my office
set up and give this presentation I
actually last year David presentation
sitting in a little cafe in the middle
of the night in Austria I've been able
to give presentations without having to
travel far it's a little difficult
sometimes to talk without an audience
because it's hard to gauge your
presentation and know precisely how
people are receiving it so that's
probably the biggest downside but from
the questions I've gotten back I think
I've done reasonably well and I would
gladly do a presentation like this again
so if you're interested in participating
next year you know please think about it
I think this has been a really great
venue and it means that later today I
could run back home and have dinner with
my family and put my son to bed tonight
so thank you don for organizing this
thanks everyone for participating if you
have any questions the last thing I'll
do is just point out that my email
address i think is on this final slide
if it is my name is Quackenbush if you
google me i'm easy to find so if you
have questions you want to send to be
happy new year from so thank you very
much enjoy the rest of your day enjoy
not being in some distant place sitting
in us in a hotel ballroom and thanks for
being with